[Musique]
dans les salles de l'espace philippe
noiret cette semaine tnet évidemment
mais deux films français surtout
puisqu'il faut aussi parler de la
production hexagonale qui kir et arrive
dans les salles et qui prend le risque
de revenir dans les salles
alors que le public a encore du mal à y
revenir
je vous parlais de deux films un film
qui s'appelle les choses qu'on dit les
choses qu'on fait un film d'amour une
grande fresque de deux heures d'amour
d'histoire d'amour de gens qui se
raconte des histoires d'amour quelque
chose de très léger de très beaux avec
camélia jordana et vincent macaigne et
niels schneider
un film de emmanuel mouret une comédie
romantique qui je pense pourra plaire
beaucoup de monde
garçons comme filles puisque voilà c'est
c'est des choses très touchante un
deuxième film aussi qui est un peu un
coup de coeur qui s'appelle énorme
l'histoire d'un homme qui
devient enceintes en même temps que sa
femme qu'il a mis enceinte par
forfanterie un film de sophie letourneur
qui est une réalisatrice trop peu
présente sur nos écrans et avec jonathan
cohen et marina foïs deux comédies donc
une romantique une plus délirantes deux
choses à aller voir à l'espace philippe
noiret dès cette semaine
[Musique]